how are you i'm great how does it feel
to be here to be on a red carpet
it feels fantastic i mean it's been a
long time uh coming
it's uh you know it's kind of like the
good weather is coming in and uh
yeah things are opening up and uh
it feels um it feels very exciting to
have the opportunity
to to bring things like shows like this
to to everyone
and it not feel as claustrophobic as it
had to be
yeah absolutely did you dress yourself
is this your first time dressing up
i know i took the sweats off and i
didn't know i wait wait i gotta i gotta
dress myself from the waist down
i know we gotta put real pants on right
i had a little bit of uh
uh help and choices but we went with a
sort of bright
uh stylistic spring look uh you know
yeah to match the good weather
you guys just got back from filming the
new season of cobra kai yes
what is in store for the fans you guys
have the
most insane amazing fan base yeah on the
planet
so give us give us well listen i would
love to tease the big stuff but i
i am under lock and key uh more
awesomeness i can promise
okay more depth of character more
left turns when you think you might be
going right okay and
uh and just um you know carrying on that
legacy but
but also bringing forth new stories that
are relevant for a young generation i
think that's
where the show really is hitting on all
cylinders now
um you know you have mothers and
daughters fathers and sons
and and everyone finding something so
we're
we're trying to uh to continue to push
that forward i think uh the fans won't
be disappointed i'm excited does it
still feel
fun and challenging to play this role
for you it does because
because you get to dive deeper into
certain more complex areas i mean the
karate kid film was
very much a black and white story good
over evil sure cobra kai you start
your allegiance changes character to
character episode to episode
as you learn more and go deeper into the
complexities of those characters and
story lines and
that's been the most rewarding part of
playing the adult version of this
kid that we all kind of grew up with
yeah i love that can we expect more
elizabeth's shoe
more elizabeth's shoe i there's the door
is always open
how's that for diplomatic okay um all
the all the uh
og cast members that have come back um
have been
so wonderful and brought such a games
that there's there's no door that's
closed in the cobra guy universe
any other guest appearances or surprises
we can expect
there will be some uh really nice talked
about
things that i can't say from the og cast
or elsewhere
i can't say you got me in a deposition
like i i don't recall at this time
uh how to answer this you know but i
plead the fifth i would
but uh awesomeness is what we're looking
for what is it like to be
at the mtv movie and tv awards in person
it's awesome it's awesome i've watched
this every year since i was four years
old so to actually be here no just
kidding not before
uh since the 80s though so to be here
actually presenting tonight it's uh it's
a thrill it's awesome
i feel like women always get asked about
fashion so i got to ask you about the
look tonight
oh right right right i mean was it fun
to get dressed up oh yes i worked very
hard on my vans tennis shoes and my
jeans
and i wasn't sure which jacket to go
with it was blue or gray and charcoal
and we went with this one
yeah well fans are very obsessed with
cobra kai i saw tanner here earlier oh
yeah
i mean what is next in in the story for
us
well that's a good question can't really
reveal anything except uh season four we
just finished two weeks ago
okay it's bigger wider deeper and it's
gonna be a lot of fun it's gonna
please the fans i'm sure what will
surprise fans about season four
what will surprise the fans the
unexpected for sure i think
the fans like to get ahead of the story
try to figure it out put the puzzle
together
um there's no way to to guess what's
going to happen okay so
they're in for a fun ride as much as i
enjoy turning the script pages and doing
the part they're going to enjoy watching
[Music]
it